this is every time that Luffy had to use
his full power in one day starting with
his fight against Rob Lucci whose leper
transformation was bigger stronger and
faster than Luffy could ever hope to
keep up with in fact Luffy had to invent
gear second and gear third to be able to
keep up and still he couldn't even move
after the fight and had to be rescued by
the race next during the word marine
Ford Luffy had to fight at full strength
but ultimately was outclassed by most of
the powerful people around him after
that he had to spend two full years
training the third time that Luffy truly
met his match was with big mom's son
katakuri whose Mochi Powers were similar
to Luffy's rubber Powers but Superior in
every way plus katakurika look into the
future it took all of Luffy's strength
and subscribing to this channel to
finally take out a yonko commander and
most recently Luffy was one-shotted by
the yonko kaido and had to train and
power up multiple times to be actually
able to fight him